hallo kinder
hallo kinder hallo papa hallo papa mama
konnte später von der arbeit nach hause
mama kommt heute später von der arbeit
nach hause
was möchtet ihr zum abendessen was
möchtet ihr zum abendessen
ich könnte etwas kochen
huhn mit kartoffeln
pasta mit tomatensauce
passt damit um
soße
fisch mit gemüse
ich möchte pizza
ich möchte auch eine pizza und eine
eiscreme
und auch einen burger
chips
ok ich bestelle etwas und denke nicht
mehr darüber nach
guten abend pizzeria eine gute pizza was
möchten sie bestellen
[Musik]
guten abend pizzeria eine gute pizza was
möchten sie bestellen
guten abend ich möchte eine pizza mit
schinken und käse eine pizza mit pilzen
und ein bürger mit kartoffelchips
bestellen
pizza mit schinken und käse
mit schinken und käse
eine pizza mit pilzen
und auch einen burger mit kartoffelchips
klar sonst noch etwas
entschuldigen sie haben sie den
laktosefreien käse
nun ist intolerant
mein sohn ist intolerant
sicher eine pizza mit laktosefreien käse
möchten sie noch etwas
zwei colas und ein bier
gut noch etwas
ein schokoladeneis 1
preis und ein pistazien eis
ein schokoladeneis
preis
erdbeer eis
und ein pistazien eis
perfekt ihre bestellung trifft in einer
halben stunde ein
ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen abend
danke gleichfalls
und du was ist dein lieblingsessen und
du was ist dein lieblingsessen
hallo hallo hallo mutti bist du im
supermarkt
hallo mutti bist du im supermarkt
ja ich kaufe etwas für das abendessen
ein
gut ich wollte dir sagen dass wir keine
milch für das frühstück mehr haben
okay was brauchst du noch
würdest du mir auch joghurt und müsli
bringen
meine favoriten mit obst oder mandeln
genau für das abendessen möchte ich
gebackenes gemüse mit schweinefleisch
machen
genau für das abendessen möchte ich
gebackenes gemüse mit schweinefleisch
machen
ich würde lieber hühnerfleisch essen
mit einem salat
wählst du
marten und mais im salat
willst du tomaten und mais im salat
ja gerne
holst du acht toastbrot
holst du auch tust brot
sicher was steht noch auf der
einkaufsliste
die einkaufs lässt
ja
die einkaufsliste
der joghurt
die so kurz
die joghurts
die milch
das müsli
die mandel
die mandeln
das obst
das schweinefleisch das schweinefleisch
das hühnerfleisch das hühnerfleisch der
salat
der salat
die salate
das gemüse
die tomate
die tomaten
der mais
das toastbrot
die toastbrote
ist das alles
papa sagt dass du auch frisches brot
kaufen sollst
genau auch frisches brot
und du
wie oft kaufst du ein und du
wie oft kaufst du ein schreibt es
einfach in die kommentare
schreibt es einfach in die kommentare
hallo marco hallo marco hallo silvia
hallo silvia
wie geht es dir wie geht es dir
mir geht es gut danke und die
mir geht es gut danke und dir
in ordnung
machst du auch einkäufer
ja ich dachte daran zu meinem geburtstag
zu hause eine kleine party zu
veranstalten ja ich dachte daran zu
meinem geburtstag zu hause eine kleine
party zu veranstalten was für eine tolle
idee
was für eine tolle idee
vielen dank aber ich weiß noch nicht was
wir essen sollen
ich helfe dir
was hast du schon und was brauchst du
noch
ich habe schon ein paar packungen
kartoffelchips und frische getränke
gekauft
ich habe schon ein paar packungen
kartoffelchips und frische getränke
gekauft
jetzt wähle ich den wein aus
daran gedacht erdnüsse zu kaufen
hast du daran gedacht erdnüsse zu kaufen
ich empfehle auch etwas salziges wie
brötchen und sein bridges
gibt es gäste die gegen milch oder
gluten allergisch sind
kauft auch laktose und glutenfreie
lebensmittel
du hast recht
weißt du wenn meine tochter eine party
organisiert
kümmere ich mich immer um die einkäufe
weißt du denn meine tochter eine party
organisiert
kümmere ich mich immer um die einkäufe
kauf auch noch verschiedene arten von
süßigkeiten
danke du warst sehr nett
es wird ein erfolg werden
ich wünsche dir einen schönen abend
vielen dank für deine ratschläge
ich wünsche dir
ebenfalls einen schönen abend
ich wünsche dir ebenfalls einen schönen
abend
was kaufst du wenn du eine party feiert
es in die kommentare
schreibt es in die kommentare abonnieren
sie unseren kanal für weitere videos
abonnieren sie unseren kanal für weitere
videos